el cacao la madera el café el aceite de
Palma o la carne de res que se consuma a
partir de ahora en la Unión Europea
deberá ser sostenible la eurocámara ha
dado luz verde definitiva con 552 votos
a favor a una nueva legislación en que
todas las empresas frente europeas como
extranjeras que quieran comercializar
este tipo de productos dentro de la
Unión Europea tendrán que demostrar que
no han contribuido en absoluto a la
deforestación las empresas además
deberán dar informaciones precisas sobre
las tierras agrícolas de donde parten
este tipo de productos para comprobar
que efectivamente no han contribuido a
la deforestación además la comisión
europea hará una clasificación de países
en el mundo que sean de mayor o menor
riesgo sobre su contribución a la
deforestación a mayor riesgo Habrá más
controles en la exportación de sus
productos y las empresas vulneran estas
normas y no cumplen con la nueva
legislación europea estarán sujetas a
multas equivalentes al 4% de su
facturación anual en la Unión Europea el
consumo de ciertos productos en la Unión
Europea son causantes de aproximadamente
el 10% de la deforestación mundial sobre
todo por el consumo de soja y aceite de
Palma una práctica con la que la Unión
Europea quiere